apple just announced the brand new mac
studio with the new m1 ultra chip and
they gave us a ton of info at the event
that's blowing people's minds but there
are actually 13 things that they did not
mention
some might be on purpose because they're
negatives while others are actually
positives and we also have some
differences between the two
configurations that they are advertising
on their website so today i'm not going
to waste any of your time telling you
exactly what's already out there but
we're only going to cover what apple did
not talk about and starting out we have
to talk about performance apple made a
huge deal about how much faster it is
than everything else both on intel side
with their new alder lake and the mac
pro with the intel chips up to 28 cores
saying that it's 60 faster 90 faster
these crazy amounts but what they didn't
mention is what programs they're
actually testing and how that applies
now we do know how the m1 max performs
in terms of cpu performance and this new
ultra is literally two of those chips
connected together so if we take a look
at the performance of the m1 max and in
cinebench the best score we got was 12
600 and we doubled that we get a score
of 25
200. now that is an incredible amount of
performance especially in that package
but that 28 core
in the mac pro that scores about 28
000 so more powerful than this m1 ultra
in terms of 100
cpu load performance now compared to
intel's latest 12th generation alder
lake the 12 900k that they also compared
it to on stage that scores about 27 000
once again having more raw performance
now here at maxtec we also know that
benchmarks aren't everything because
depending on the program that you're
using these apple silicon chips could be
so much faster even though the route
performance is worse for example my 15
000 mac pro gets smoked even by macbook
air in certain tasks because of software
optimization for these these unified soc
chips that have really high memory
bandwidth a lot of memory channels and
dedicated decoders and encoders that
make it really fast so we will have to
see how these computers compare once we
get them in and we actually ordered
three mac studios three different
configurations to test out and compare
so we will see how it stacks up against
intel's alder lake with an rtx 3090 with
real projects not just the charts that
apple showed off so make sure you guys
click that subscribe button down below
if you guys don't want to miss that
video and to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers now for number two
we have to switch over to graphics and
talk about the m1 max which might seem
kind of boring because we already have
it in our macbook pros but there's one
thing that they didn't mention and that
is the wattage and the frequency we know
that even in the 16-inch macbook pro the
m1 max only peaked at 46 watts being
maxed out completely when the design is
a 60 watt chip and with apple's graphs
when they compared it to other gpus they
show it off as 60 watts now that might
mean that if you're getting an m1 max in
a max studio it could actually perform
better than the same chip in the macbook
pro so we could get some extra
performance there now the third thing
that apple didn't mention
is the fact that the m1 ultra has a
different cooling system than the same
ax studio with the m1 max now we first
saw this by comparing the technical
specifications and seeing that the m1
ultra is almost two pounds heavier than
the same max studio with the m1 max now
of course the actual cpu soc is larger
but that can account for a two pound
difference and my thought was that they
could literally have a different cooling
system with maybe even a single fan in
the m1 max because that's enough worth
but upgrade for the higher end one but
today morning we have some new news
where apple replied to the verge and
gave him info that the m1 ultra actually
has a cooling system made out of copper
instead of aluminum now we don't know
what other differences there are in
terms of size fans or anything like that
but we do plan to take these apart both
configurations and take a look inside as
soon as we get them so make sure you
guys notifications are enabled and we
also know that copper is about three
times heavier than aluminum which
definitely makes the whole system
heavier now if this copper cooler is a
lot better that could also mean that the
m1 ultra might not be any louder or
hotter and it might actually be less hot
and less loud than the m1 max and that's
something we love to dig into and test
like we have with the macbooks and
previous computers now for number four
we found something very interesting
about apple's charts in relation to the
m1 ultra we know that the m1 max runs it
up to 60 watts and they showed it off
but for the ultra we only saw it running
at about 105
which is not double the scaling now that
could mean that apple they are limiting
either just the wattage or even the
frequency just like we saw in the
macbooks in the highest end 64 core
graphics and one ultra might not have
perfect scaling compared to the 48 core
version meaning that you're paying a lot
more money but not seeing you know a
linear increase in performance and we
saw that with the m1 max in the macbooks
where the 24 core was the sweet spot so
we will test out that 48 core versus the
64 and see how much faster the 64 core
actually is now with that the next one
that we need to talk about are the
prices when apple showed off the prices
on stage we saw that two thousand dollar
model which was lower than expected and
the four thousand dollar model which was
a big jump but then when you went into
their configurator online you saw that
the four thousand dollars isn't the 64
core that they gave us all the
performance numbers of it is actually
the 48 core version and even though
going from the 24 core bin 2 000 one
it's only 200 bucks to get the m1 max
with 32 cores the jump for the 64 core
is much bigger than that and that leads
me into number six and that's the fact
that even though apple advertised those
high-end configurations most people
don't need them when we see all those
scores we want to buy that
but you have to keep in mind that when
you're spending that extra thousand
bucks you're only getting some extra
graphics scores you don't get any more
bandwidth any extra encoders or decoders
ports none of that and unless you are
maxing out that 48 core m1 ultra in most
workloads you're not going to see much
of a difference spending that much more
money and like i said that could be the
sweet spot whereas online when you're
looking at apple's prompts as far as the
gpu cores and even the ram
they say well if you think that you're
gonna need more you can't upgrade it
later you should probably think about it
doing it now they want you to do that
but as we know when we did our ram
comparison we saw almost no difference
between even 32 and 64 gigs just because
of how well the unified memory works so
most people don't really need to spend
1800 extra now i actually made a guide
for people that are buying the mac
studio helping you guys decide what
configuration is best so if you guys
want to watch that you can see it after
this video now the next one has to do
with that hdmi port they showed it off
they showed it connected to a 4k tv
alongside monitors but
it does not come with hdmi 2.1 meaning
that you're limited to 4k 60 hertz which
is really weird because so many tvs now
are coming out with hdmi 2.1 new
consoles are different graphics cards so
this port is definitely limited and that
leads me into the next one and that is
thankfully
even though on stage they said you can
connect up to four 6k xdr monitors and
in the past that always meant if you buy
the highest in configuration you could
do up to that many but in this case if
you're somebody that wants multiple
displays you don't have to buy the m1
ultra even the base model can actually
support
four of these displays which is really
awesome to see
now the next one is also with those
ports and that is the fact that these
are thunderbolt 4 ports meaning each one
of those ports has its own controller
meaning that if you need more than four
thunderbolt ports you don't have to buy
the m1 ultra to get the extra two to be
thunderbolt in the front because you can
buy a simple owc hub and each one of
those can actually turn into three
thunderbolt ports without limiting your
bandwidth and still giving you a lot of
flexibility now the next one is the
power usage now sure apple talked about
peak power usage and how that compares
but they didn't mention the idle power
usage and we just found that online and
it is an insanely low 11 watts now just
to blow your guys's mind if you buy the
cheapest weakest acor mac pro it's when
it sits there not doing anything it uses
over 100 watts of power and if you get a
fully loaded 28 core model that is over
300 watts of power which is absolutely
insane whereas the whole apple
mac studio is less than that even if
you're maxing out the gpus in your
maximum of the cpus and running a
display
it's just crazy how efficient these
things are
now the next one that is very
interesting is that when we saw this
thing being revealed and it's basically
a big mac mini
that actually didn't mean that they
replaced the mac mini at least the intel
version when you go on their site they
are still selling the intel mac mini
which blows my mind and what this means
is that if the 2000 mac studio is too
expensive for you you don't need the m1
max you might have wanted an m1 pro
apple does have that in the work so
they're still gonna be putting out
another mac mini name the mac mini that
will come in at that lower price point
better than the m1 but cheaper than this
mac studio so you guys can hold off for
that and then the last one that i want
to talk about is that
this mac studio might be a replacement
to the 27-inch imac at least for now
when they talked about it on stage i
kept referencing the 27-inch imac and
how much better this is and then right
after the event they took the 27-inch
imac off their website completely so
it's only showing the 24 inch and one
imac now now that literally means that
instead of buying an imac apple wants
you to buy a mac studio and this new
display and it kind of makes sense
because they want to recoup the r d cost
of creating this display they stopped
doing it before because it was just too
expensive didn't make the money but now
that they're coming back out with it
they would rather have more people buy
this instead of buying an imac there's
still a big jump in pricing from where
the imac was the 27-ish for 1800 and now
if you buy this display and the cheapest
mac studio you're looking at
3600 so hopefully at some point we get
something else but at this point the mac
studio basically discontinued that 27
inch imac and then the last one actually
this is the last of number 13 is
applecare
this mac studio is all sealed up even
though we are going to take it apart
apple doesn't really want you to
and because so many people are worried
about not being able to upgrade and the
memory going bad or the ssd apple is now
giving us apple care that is a yearly
subscription that doesn't just expire
after two or three years this can be
running indefinitely now 60 bucks a year
i don't know what you guys think about
if it's expensive or not but if you just
spend eight grand on a mac studio you
spec it out completely being able to
cover it for 600 bucks for 10 years
making sure year five or six or seven
down the line if something goes wrong it
is fixed that is really nice instead of
only having coverage for the first three
years and then when stuff starts wearing
out you're out of luck so this is really
cool that apple is allowing you to have
this extra peace of mind so there you
guys go that is 13 different things that
apple did not mention at their event
that we now know we'll be getting three
of these as well as displays and other
accessories very soon doing comparisons
tear downs showing you guys all of the
information that most people don't cover
so make sure you guys subscribe by
clicking that circle above check out one
of those excellent videos right over
there this has been max and i i'll see
you in the next video